you know the word grifter is way
overplayed these days especially online
where the average internet user only has
a vocabulary of 17 words to begin with
any term that makes it into that limited
arsenal will inevitably be utilized with
great and undo frequency the problem is
that terms which were once descriptively
useful end up shorn of all meaning this
has happened with words like trauma and
outrage for example and of course racism
and sex sexism not to mention the big
one woman
but i don't want to see the word grifter
neutralized and negated in that way as
it's a very expressive illustrative term
and that's why i will not say that race
hustlers like ebermex candy and colin
kaepernick are grifters now on first
blush the description would seem to fit
them as snug and comfortably as a
well-made sweater i mean a grifter after
all is a con artist a swindler a
carnival barker a fleece or a fraudster
both of these men live up to all of
those adjectives
but the other definitional aspect of a
grifter is that he's petty he's small
time he's small scale operating on the
level of a you know pickpocket or a card
shark race hustlers in our country today
however especially the most famous and
visible ones like kendy and kaepernick
and sharpton
and that lawyer who shows up on the
scene nine seconds after any black man
is shot by the cops
they're all running a very large-scale
con
they may be petty people who got into
this game for their own superficial
reasons
personal fame and wealth being the
primary motivators as always but
the effect they have on our society is
anything but smaller petty
they're closer to you know bernie madoff
level than pickpockets
their schemes are sweeping far-reaching
and they've managed to inflict
widespread devastation so it's worth
pausing to appreciate
whenever one of these degenerate
sleazeballs accidentally reveals
themselves for who they are and over the
last few days it just so happens that
two of them both kendy and kaepernick
have done just that so starting with
candy on friday he shared an article
from the hill published a few days prior
which reports on a survey finding that
more than a third of white college
applicants
lie on their applications in order to
increase their chances of being admitted
amazingly kendi shared this article
along with a caption accurately
describing the survey's findings he
wrote quote more than a third of white
students lie about their race on college
applications and about half of those
applicants lied about being native
american more than three-fourths of
these students who lied about their race
were accepted
what makes this amazing of course
is that this fact completely undermines
kendy's case
indeed it wouldn't be too far to say
that this fact alone
single-handedly dismantles candy's world
view in its entirety
his vision of the world or at least his
vision of western culture
is that it's structured around and
defined by systemic racism against
quote-unquote people of color
but how could there be systemic racism
against non-white people
if a white person's way of gaming that
system is to pretend to be non-whites
you're not gonna find any analog to this
in the you know history of the human
race there's no analog there's no
nothing comparable
nowhere else on earth at any other point
in history
can you find an example of a minority
group being systemically oppressed and
people own the dominant majority group
responding to that oppression by
pretending to be in the minority group
so they can personally benefit
doesn't make any sense there weren't a
lot of you know non-jews in germany
pretending to be jewish
it would go the other way around you'd
pretend to not be jewish
i don't think you could have gone to
rwanda in the mid 90s and found very
many people pretending to be in an
ethnic minority group there
in fact there weren't any whites
pretending to be black here in america
during segregation
but there are now
because the systemic discrimination cuts
in precisely the opposite direction
so why did kendi share this then
what point did he think it would make
well to understand that you have to
remember that the race hustlers along
with being driven by greed and arrogance
are also died in the wool anti-white
bigots they hate white people
and so for kendy all he saw in the
headline was that white people did
something bad you know they lied on an
application and that's as far as as his
thought process went his brain said look
white people did bad thing and he shared
it
only later did he connect the dots or
rather other people connected the dots
and alerted him to the problem so he
responded by deleting the original post
and then a short time later in defending
himself against charges of being a
stupid self-contradicting hypocrite
kendy tweeted this
they
talking about as critics lie about what
i said to defend the lying of white
college applicants here is their
tortured line of thinking
when white applicants think they have an
advantage by lying about being a person
of color
then that means they do have an
advantage which then means structural
racism doesn't exist
they imagine white people are
disadvantaged while white people are on
the higher end of nearly every racial
disparity they imagine black and native
people have racial advantages at the
same time black and native people are on
the lowest end of nearly every racial
disparity smh
well by the way kenny no we're not
saying that systemic discrimination
doesn't exist
no we're saying it does exist but that
it exists against white people we're
saying that you benefit from it as a
black man
the problem for candy is that white
applicants
yeah they think they have an advantage
and in fact actually they do as he said
in his original post more than
three-fourths of the whites who lie
about the race are accepted
whites perceived that it would be to
their advantage if they weren't white
and their perceptions are vindicated by
the results
there are plenty of additional lines of
evidence proving that there is no
systemic racism against non-whites in
this country but this one line of
evidence is perhaps the most powerful
it's conclusive all on its own
if the system is biased against a
certain group you could not possibly
game that system by pretending to be in
that very group period
and so kendy's whole life's work is
reduced to rubble
by his own words which is fantastic
and then there's kaepernick
in kaepernick's case uh you know if you
can put aside the moral and ethical
problems for a moment
you might almost have to admire his
hustle
it's it's it's
in a way sort of brilliant
that he was he was flunking out of the
nfl let me just think about this think
about think about what happened with
kaepernick
flunking out of the nfl
suffering through a 10 loss season
uh with the 49ers back in 2016. he had
just been benched for blaine gabbert
which is the nfl equivalent of losing a
beauty pageant to you know rachel levine
and he found himself start staring at a
career as a bench rider hopping from one
team to another on one year contracts
getting paid the veteran minimum which
is still like almost a million dollars
uh but even so in nfl terms pretty
pretty low salary and he decided in that
moment to pivot and become a social
justice crusader instead and the career
change has made him a household name
whereas before he would have been about
as famous and widely discussed as joe
flacco is today
um now he's uh this famous
household name it's also made him far
richer than he would have been otherwise
with all kinds of promotional deals and
shoe deals and books and everything
he also has his own netflix show now
it's called colin in black and white and
it's being largely hailed by critics
because critics are contractually
obligated to hail anything kaepernick
does but the show's been mocked and
derided by everybody else
thanks largely to one scene which went
viral over the weekend
where kaepernick
biting off more than he could chew
actually compares the nfl draft to a
slave auction
watch this
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that shape there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it actually sounds more like he's
describing you know tsa screening
poke prod and examine you no dignity
left intact but uh no he's describing
the nfl nfl players are slaves he says
the process of becoming an nfl player is
dehumanizing and degrading
which is very different from what he
said literally two weeks ago
when he did an interview with ebony
magazine and claimed that he's still
training every day in hopes of becoming
an nfl player again
this is what he said two weeks ago
he said i'm still up at 5am training
five days a week making sure i'm
prepared to take a team to a super bowl
again that's not something i will ever
let go of regardless of the actions of
32 teams and their partners to deny me
employment
the same way i was persistent in high
school is the same way i'm going to be
persistent here
of course kaepernick can train all he
wants and it's not going to change the
fact that he's a 32 year old former
backup who was washed up in 2016 the
last time he played
also the problem with his training is
that it mostly consists of him jogging
through his neighborhood screaming the
word racist at all the trees squirrels
and birds he sees all that aside though
if being an nfl player is like being a
slave
why is he still trying to get into the
nfl
why has he spent six years crying that
he can't be a slave
well because he's full of it of course
slavery and professional football are it
turns out a little bit different
football players are paid millions of
dollars
they get to live in their own homes very
big and expensive homes too they choose
to be football players that's a big one
they're admired and envied by millions
of adoring fans if kaepernick thinks
that any of this bears any resemblance
to the lot of a slave then his talents
as a historian are even less impressive
than his talents as a quarterback
but he doesn't actually think that
though he's a con artist just saying
whatever he needs to say in the moment
just like candy just like the rest of
them
and it would almost be funny to see them
flailing about like this funny in a
pitiful sort of way
if it weren't for the very real very
widespread damage
that they're doing to our culture
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends